Zadie Smith is one of the most widely
read personal essayists alive. Well,
sort of. With over 20 essays published
in The New Yorker alone and scores of
readers around the world, her literary
success didn't come about overnight. And
to create the writing system that helped
her achieve it, she had to do something
that most personal essayists couldn't
imagine. She removed herself entirely
from her essays. So, why was this
necessary and more importantly, why is
this something that should worry
independent writers publishing on
Substack? Well, to answer that, I need
to ask you this. Have you ever tried to
listen to someone describe last night's
dream? Now, you might nod along, but the
dream doesn't mean anything to you. It's
really easy to feel like a dream is
meaningful and interesting because it's
so vivid in our mind, but dreams are
made out of symbols and each symbol is a
clown car filled with the dreamer's
private memories and associations that
no one else shares. Personal essays work
the same way. The ones filling Substack
right now are earnest and carefully
written, but they're made of private
symbols and experiences that fall flat
with readers because they arrive without
those associations. They can read the
surface of your text, but they can't get
inside. And that brings me back to Zadie
Smith. When the young writer arrived at
the University of Cambridge, she was
expressive, passionate, and chaotic. And
she wrote from a deeply personal
perspective. But, the university wanted
her to be formal, objective, composed,
and to write from an impersonal
perspective. So, the first essay she
wrote came back with a single comment.
"This is not an essay." By the end of
the first year, she was so held back by
the university's demands that when the
woman who would become one of the most
celebrated essayists of her generation
sat down to write her final exam, she
wrote
nothing. But, everything changed for
Zadie when she started experimenting
with the impersonal essay and discovered
a framework that would transform the way
that she approached essays, and one that
she still uses today, 50 years later.
Zadie Smith stopped writing about
herself, and she started writing about
the world. Developing an approach to
essay writing that would both allow her
to show up as her unique expressive
self, and still give readers what they
need. And in so doing, she sidestepped a
massive risk that not many essayists
ever think about. But, I'll come back to
that in a moment. So, why did Zadie
Smith pretty much remove herself from
her essays? And why has that allowed her
to become one of the most popular
essayists of her generation? Well, after
bombing her first year exams, she
discovered three writers who changed
everything she thought she knew about
essays. All three were Kingsman,
Cambridge through and through. But,
unlike most of the Cambridge elite,
these writers all came from
working-class backgrounds, just like
Zadie Smith. And it showed up in their
work. They wrote with anger and
precision and wit, not about what
literature meant to them personally, but
about what it reveals about class,
power, and the systems that they live
inside. Despite their impersonal style,
their subject was not a topic for
cocktail parties, but a living concern.
So, Zadie Smith tried this out herself.
When she wrote an essay about a 17th
century poem, she stopped asking what it
meant to her, and started asking what it
reveals about the world, about English
attitudes to land and capital, and who
gets to own what. She still cared about
the subject passionately, but that
passion was directed outward at the
topic, and not inward at herself. And
that's the difference between the
personal and the impersonal essay. The
personal essay puts the writer at the
center, but readers of essays aren't
primarily interested in you. They want
to use your writing to understand the
world, and the impersonal essay gives
them that. The writer becomes a guide,
directing their attention outward
through a window onto something that the
reader can see. Now, the terrain of the
impersonal essay is not personal
experience, but ideas. The key isn't to
subtract the passion, it's to sublimate
that passion, investing it into an
object that the reader can see, touch,
and stand next to.
That's what Zadie Smith discovered when
she reinvented the personal essay, and
it's what made her essays reach farther
than any personal essay ever could. This
is the most important part of Zadie
Smith's framework for writing essays. By
focusing on the ideas rather than the
person thinking them, she asks readers
not to relate to her, but to be in
relation to her. As Zadie Smith herself
puts it, "We aren't required to be like
one another, or even to like one another
to be in relation. We just need to be
willing to create and enter spaces in
which solidarity is one of the
possibilities."
That's what the practice of essaying is
to me, a stumbling attempt to recreate
in language a common space, one that is
open to all. It's in that optimistic
spot that I set out my stall, yes, and
my ideas and arguments such as they are,
sure, but without demanding to see
anyone's identifying papers in the
opening paragraph. So, what is this
framework, and how can you use it to
write better essays? Well, you can
picture your essay as a rectangle with
four arrows on the corners, and then one
halfway along the top, and another
halfway along the bottom. So, six total,
moving clockwise. In the center of the
rectangle is the title, where it keeps
you anchored to the question every time
you drift off. And so, the first thing
you write is arrows one and six. That's
the introduction and conclusion. Zadie
still does this 50 years later. Write
the opening line and then the closing
line. And now the essay is simple. All
that's left is just a four arrow affair.
So, what are those arrows? Well, arrow
one is the introduction. So, here you're
going to state your position and make
the promise that the essay will keep.
And you've got to commit to it. Don't
waffle about. Make your position clear.
The introduction makes a promise to the
reader about the place that you're going
to take them.
Arrow two is development. Build on the
promise that you made in the
introduction with the first layer of
your argument. That's the evidence and
the reasoning that begins to make good
on the promise that you just made. Now,
although you're making an argument here,
don't be afraid of using metaphor. As
Zadie Smith says, a metaphor will tend
to be more comprehensible to the general
reader Piketty.
Next is arrow three, the devil's
advocate. With the argument laid out,
it's time to stress test it. So, either
push it deeper with a second layer of
nuance or complicate it. Steel man the
opposition, introduce the strongest
counter argument, or acknowledge the
limits of the claim and where it gets
difficult. This section is what
distinguishes an essay from a speech.
So, a speech is just an assertion, but
to essay means to try, which is to say
try out ideas. So, you need to write in
such a way that the reader feels like
you're trying out the idea rather than
forcing it upon them. So, arrow three is
where that thinking happens. Arrow four
is the wind down. From here you can see
the finish line. Now, this isn't the
conclusion yet, but you're gathering
momentum toward it. So, don't introduce
any new threads, but do start to weave
in the previous ones into something more
cohesive and whole. The argument is no
longer expanding, it's beginning to
resolve and come together. Arrow five is
the reprise, but with variations. So,
material from earlier in the essay is
echoed, but here it's transformed by
everything that came in between. The
reader hears familiar ideas again, but
now they mean something more. This is
what gives your essay that sense of
inevitability, the feeling that the
ending was always where you were headed.
And finally, arrow six is the
conclusion, home straight. And since you
already wrote this at the start of the
essay, you arrive at the destination
announced in arrow one. And this gives
reader the satisfaction of completing a
closed loop, and it's what gives your
essay as a whole a sense of coherence
and unity. Now, the best part of this
framework is that ruthless forward
thrust. The arrows only go in one
direction, so you're never doubling back
or losing the plot. Now, if you write
personal essays, then you might look at
this and think that such a structure
might constrain your thinking. But, on
the contrary, it frees up your thinking
by removing every decision except the
next one. But, it doesn't stop there
because beyond that forward thrust, this
type of essay also allows you to connect
with a more general reader. Personal
essays connect only with people who
share enough of your experience to
follow you in, but the impersonal essay
is built out of ideas and out of the
world. So, they're available to anyone
who's willing to think and look,
regardless of their biography and
background. But, not only does it reach
more readers, it also creates a deeper
connection with them. Personal essays
ask readers to relate to the writer, to
come over to their place, to step into
their private world. But, impersonal
essays ask readers to be in relation to
the writer, to sit together on a park
bench side by side looking out at the
world. And surprisingly, that can feel
more intimate, not less, because you're
thinking alongside someone rather than
watching them think. Impersonal essays
also let you be passionate without being
self-indulgent.
Nobody ever accused Zadie Smith of being
objective and boring. Her fierce
convictions are everywhere in her
essays, but they're just below the
surface. They appear as arguments and
not confessions. So, her passion goes
into the subject, which lets her readers
think about ideas and the world rather
than the writer's feelings. It simply
wouldn't have been possible for Zadie
Smith to achieve this level of literary
success without avoiding the pitfalls of
the personal essay. So, ask yourself
this: What's the value of this essay? Is
the reader going to use it to understand
the writer? Or are they going to use it
to understand the world? Now, Zadie
Smith is clearly a world-class writer
with decades of experience, but what if
you're not? Can anyone start writing
essays that connect with readers today?
The answer is yes. But, first, you need
to solve the problem that stops most
writers before they begin. The belief
that your everyday experience isn't
interesting enough to write about. So,
watch this video next because it's going
to show you how to mine the ordinary for
what's valuable and true about the
world. Because Zadie Smith didn't need
an extraordinary life. She needed
perspective on the world and a
rectangle. And once you know how to find
the extraordinary in what you already
have, you're ready to write the kind of
essay that connects with readers. So, be
sure to go check it out.